es encontrar vías que puedan estimular y activar
esas células madre que ya están en el cerebro
para reaccionar y responder apropiadamente al daño
y repararlo.
Ese será el futuro.
Habrá medicamentos que harán eso.
Pero la otra vía es lanzarse en paracaídas dentro de las células,
trasplantarlas,
para reemplazar células moribundas o perdidas, incluso en el cerebro.
Y quiero hablarles ahora de un experimento,
es un ensayo clínico que hicimos,
y que se completó recientemente
junto con colegas en UCL,
David Miller en particular.
Este estudio fue muy sencillo.
Tomamos pacientes con esclerosis múltiple
y nos planteamos una simple pregunta:
¿Protegerían las células madre de la médula ósea
a sus nervios?
Lo que hicimos fue que tomamos la médula ósea,
desarrollamos las células madre en el laboratorio,
y las inyectamos de nuevo en la vena.
Estoy tratando de que suene muy sencillo.
Pero le tomó 5 años a mucha gente, ¿está bien?
Me sacó las canas
y causó todo tipo de problemas.
Sin embargo, conceptualmente es un experimento esencialmente simple.
Entonces las hemos puesto en la vena, ¿verdad?
Con el objetivo de comprobar si fue exitoso o no,
tomamos el nervio óptico
como nuestra medida de resultado.
Esa es una buena manera para comprobar el avance de la esclerosis múltiple,
porque lamentablemente los pacientes sufren
de problemas de visión:
pérdida de visión, visión borrosa.
Y así, comprobamos el tamaño del nervio óptico
usando los escáneres con David Miller
tres veces --a los doce meses, a los seis meses,
y antes de la inyección--
y pueden ver la línea roja descender ligeramente.
Eso está diciéndonos que el nervio óptico se está reduciendo,
lo que tiene sentido porque los nervios están muriendo.
Entonces pusimos la inyección de células madre
y repetimos la medición dos veces
--a los tres meses y a los seis meses--
y casi para nuestra sorpresa,
la línea subió.
Eso sugiere que la intervención
ha sido protectora.
No creo que lo que pasó
es que esas células madre hubieran creado nueva mielina
o nuevos nervios.
Lo que pienso que han hecho es que han estimulado
las células madre endógenas o las células precursoras,
para que hagan su trabajo: despertar, generar nueva mielina.
Esta es una prueba de concepto.
Y estoy muy emocionado con eso.
Entonces quiero terminar con el tema con el que empecé,
que fue regeneración y esperanza.
De ese modo, le he preguntado a John
cuáles son sus expectativas para el futuro.
John: Esperaría que
en el futuro,
a través de la investigación que ustedes están haciendo,
podamos obtener una cura,
para que la gente como yo pueda llevar una vida normal.
Eso lo dice todo.
Me gustaría terminar agradeciendo a John en primer lugar,
gracias a John por permitirme compartir
sus ideas y estos cortos con ustedes.
Pero también me gustaría decir a John y a los demás
que mi punto de vista es: tengo esperanzas en el futuro.
Creo que las tecnologías disruptivas,
como las de las células madre que he tratado de explicarles hoy,
ofrecen la verdadera esperanza.
Y pienso que el día en que podamos ser capaces
de reparar los cerebros lesionados
está más cerca de lo que pensamos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)